federal investigators are still
examining the explosives recovered after
last month's bombing spree in Austin
Texas only on CBS this morning we have a
look at the secure site where the Bureau
of Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms and
Explosives works to prevent future
attacks Jeff Pegues joins us from the
ATF facility in Huntsville Alabama
Jeff good morning good morning we are
inside an ATF lab and everything you see
here lay it out on these tables is an
element that someone is used to build an
explosive ATF investigators they
experiment with these elements and use
them to investigate bombings at the
ATF's explosive testing range you can
feel the power of the blasts even from
200 yards away Austin Texas was left on
edge in the wake of multiple package
bombings last month here ATF agents have
been studying similar homemade
explosions what kind of damage might it
have done had there been people around
that you would have people with internal
injuries to their lungs and ears also
their brain if they're right up on it
the ATF sent hundreds of agents to
Austin and followed thousands of leads
some of the most important pieces of
evidence from the Austin attacks are the
bomb fragments themselves many of which
are being held in this secure lab
outside Washington DC so tape is very
good at retaining fingerprints tape is a
penis the ATF's JD Underwood says what
is left of an explosive device is
preserved for a reason we're gonna try
to recreate we're gonna collect as much
of the evidence left over from the bomb
it doesn't all go away
the devastation left behind is stunning
that's like we're on the surface of the
Moon it causes a good-sized crater at
the ATF's National Center for explosives
training and research in a Huntsville
agent stockpile pieces used to make
homemade bombs there are batteries
timers switches and different types of
liquids and powders for explosives
those Tom Cheetham the special agent in
charge of the Washington field division
says the ease of making bombs has
increased their frequency the numbers
are high I think the average person
would be surprised to know that ATF
investigates hundreds of bombings a year
in 2017 ATF labs like this one help
close about 314 explosives cases the
Austin bombing investigation that is
still an open case the ATF is still
following up on leads and agents still
have questions about the explosives that
were used
bianna it's fascinating to see how they
recreate the remnants from the bomb as
well great to see you out there as well
Jeff thank you